i'm justin roiland and this is the wired
auto complete interview
[Music]
that i guess is that what happened
there's a lot that happened i mean you
want to get into the
is this therapy you want me to really go
go into it
[Music]
who does justin roiland
eat
because i'm a cannibal no no it's gonna
say
oh voice and adventure time oh man i vo
i voiced lemongrab
in adventure time and that voice
really screwed my voice up my eye that's
the voice that taught me my limits of
what my vocal cords are
capable of and where the line is and
when i need to stop and i think every
voice actor when they're starting
figures that out and yeah it's like a
quick little like
you know he's just a psycho he's like a
weird like he's like um a trouble i'm
not gonna say a psychopath he's just a
troubled character he's got
he's got he he doesn't quite fit in he's
got issues
no i mean not like you know and then i
had to get really high pitched you know
with him yeah crazy who does justin
roiland's voice and rick and morty i
voiced rick and morty so it's like uh
oh my god rick uh we're in real trouble
today you know we're we have to do this
stupid interview thing morty relax don't
be offensive
don't be offensive to these you know you
know it's like yeah that's a bad thing
but whatever i do them
and then i do the me seeks which is like
hi mr me sex
and i do mr poopy butthole which is
basically kind of almost the same thing
like oh
i'm
i'm scared rick
and then there's like probably a bunch
of other random stuff in in
in odds and ends in between there but
those are the main ones who does justin
roiland
hate the most no uh voice and invincible
doug cheston i voice doug how do you how
do you know how do you not remember i've
always dug chested in that what's wrong
with you people good old doug chest
cheston i don't even remember what i did
i think i was just like i'm doug cheston
i don't know hey i'm doug i don't know
how i can't remember
i mean is is kirkman going to give doug
cheston a spin-off come on robert
kirkman
let's build that doug chest and spin-off
now we could do something better
together than that who does justin royal
and
voice and solar opposites okay i voiced
corvo in solar opposites
he's just like um he's the serious one
he's the
grumpy
i i don't want to call him a straight
man because he definitely can get caught
up in insane shenanigans but he's just
like you know terry uh terry yemulek uh
jesse everyone we have to meet in the
living room right now because i i want
to we all have to watch
you know uh
red october deep red october and then
they're just like i i don't want to do
that like you uh okay
let's uh
let's move on to the next card
oh what do we got here another card how
to contact justin roiland i try to
i try to be kind of
contactless i suppose i mean i'm on i'm
on instagram but i don't really
look at my dms i don't really understand
how that whole thing works i it's just
broken i'm just gonna say it instagram
for me and my account is completely
broken therefore i don't think there is
a way and i kind of like that you know
maybe through my agency uta or
mail a letter to
yeah mail a letter to uta i guess
how many voices does justin roiland do
ah i always say i'm the guy with three
or four voices
i mean
i probably if i i probably could come up
with more but then
they still would be in the
it still would be recognizably me when i
was a kid i remember like rob paulson i
could like pick him out like i didn't
know who he was when i was a kid but i
could pick his voice out uh same with
tres mcneil
and look i get it it's like all right
enough i've heard this voice on every
cartoon we need new voices no i get i
get it i get it i was there as a kid but
hey man
those guys are
badass legendary amazing i i you i try
to use them as much as i possibly can so
nowadays which is is and they're just
incredible and wow some of the sweetest
people you'll ever meet so uh
so you know think about me that way you
know what i mean like yeah i do like
four voices but come on how did justin
roiland and dan harmon meet oh that's a
good one so we met through a thing
called channel 101 that dan and rob dan
harmon and rab schrab created i want i i
want to say
our first like kind of encounter was
late 2003 and then we became friends
with dan me siobhan my buddy sivan uh
nigerian and abu gaithe became friends
with uh dan and rob in 2004 and then the
friendship just kind of just you know it
was
that's where you know 2004 2005 we were
just like making shows together hanging
out at each other's apartment all the
time like we were just like all of us
were like just glued
together to me it was that was
that was my college that was my training
that was like my real training of like
that's how i got better as a writer as a
as a
director of animation as a
just everything comedy pacing all of it
anyway that was all because of dan and
and rob creating that thing and
i would not be where i'm at without
channel 101. was rick and morty
uh made for stoners uh no we just made
no i mean it i see it why it would
appeal to them but no we weren't
thinking about that was rick and morty
inspired by back to the future
yeah you know i'm not gonna lie i mean
everyone knows like the original
original short i made which is super
gross on purpose gross i was trying to
shock an audience
so and don't confuse the art with the
artist as jack black says uh how rick
and morty is made um you know how any
cartoon is made what do you want from me
go online and google cartoons why rick
and morty take so long ah
that's a long answer but i'll just say
the pursuit of perfection
um the
sometimes uh misguided pursuit of
perfection you know just a lot of
changes happen you know how
to rick and morty dance yeah i'm not
gonna go there so sorry
hey what do you know
lots of good questions today justin
roiland nft i have mixed feelings on
nfts like my whole thing with nfts is
like how do you do them in a way that's
there's some sort of utility some sort
of function some sort of i don't want to
say game but like
something that you can actually do and
it's not just a jpeg that you own i
think it's the early days and then of
course there's the environmental stuff
which i think
everybody in the scene is very very very
aware of and focused on
trying to fix and i have a few really
cool ideas that are very early that i
can't talk about that
are literally using nfts to
fix
environment like big environmental
issues i like i mean i don't know i dip
my toe in the waters what do you that's
it that's all i did justin roiland's
signature
that's that's the basic you know fast
signature justin roiland
vr game yeah i made a vr game it's
called trover save the universe but it's
also not vr you can get it on all the
consoles you can play it in non-vr mode
on the switch the playstation the xbox
we learned a lot and now we're making a
traditional non-vr game which is a
first-person shooter
uh
action-adventure comedy it's got talking
guns the guns are your companions you
know sort of like dragon age style
companions you know so they they're not
constantly blabbing but they really are
how you communicate with npcs in the
world um dialogue tree stuff like
and what depending on what gun you have
is going to depend on like how the
conversation kind of come you know
plays out and then there's just a lot
there's a lot to this game and i'm
really excited to reveal more as we lead
up to launch but uh yeah it's it's
called high on life and it's gonna be on
xbox uh
in october
in october
fingers crossed justin roiland
smiling friends uh yeah i mean i i love
smiling friends uh zach and michael are
really close friends of mine i i can't
take any credit for what they've done
with that show it's all them 100 they're
brilliant geniuses i'm just so happy
because like michael has just killed it
with like yolo and
and smiling friends and then koala man
which is coming soon to hulu and it's
just like he is like he's insane he he's
an insane brilliant genius and zac and
zach is like you know if you're online
at all you know you know zack is amazing
justin roiland the boys yeah so um me
and ben bayeth my brother-in-law wrote a
boyish short for the animated diabolical
boys kind of spin-off animated thing and
um
that was really fun it was a fun process
you know we pitched the idea it was
something i wanted to do somewhere else
at some point but i was like ah yeah
it's perfect for this universe so just
the idea of really superheroes you know
there's one part i would change but one
one line of dialogue i wish i could
change but other than that it's it's i'm
really happy with it what is so what is
solar opposites
about solar opposites is about uh
a team of aliens uh two adults and the
replicants and a pupa which is very
important and they
escape from their homeworld which was
hit by an asteroid and they land on
earth and they're just trying to fit in
and figure it out yeah there's a lot
there's a lot to the show it is it is
amazing uh and season three is like
pushing it to a whole new level of
incredible and
i couldn't be more excited is solar
opposites
good uh well i guess that depends on who
you ask you know uh beauty is in the eye
of the beholder or whatever you know uh
comedy's subjective i think it's really
good i i
i love it i i and especially where we're
going now where we're kind of building
things
out we're building the universe out
we're getting more serialized on the
alien side of the stuff not just in the
wall and that really excites the shot of
me that we're doing that like that's
like
yeah that's really cool so i think it's
good but i'm biased you know what is
blank solar opposites what is pupa solar
app what is pupa uh so pupa is this
little uh baby slash pet slash
little creature
that stores all of the homeworld's uh
information in its dna and when
uh a team of uh schulerians land on a
new planet the goal is to
help the pupa
terraform help the pupa reach
to a stage of complete terraforming and
it turns into
a new schlorp a new planet shlorp and um
so the pupa is incredibly important to
the mission but of course our characters
are idiots and they didn't study any of
this and they they don't know what is
going on and
anyway so that's the pupa
does molly die yeah have you did you not
see it she died she died what do you
yeah i mean you know like i think i
think i think some of the best shows
it's like yeah man they're dead this
isn't uh
star wars where everyone just keeps
coming back to life i'm trying to think
of a better example but anyway yeah no
this she's dead she's gone it's a little
more game of thronesy it's it's awful
it's heartbreaking that episode was very
manipulative
in terms of
making you sad and that's what we were
that's what we were going for and we're
sorry but uh
but we're having fun role playing as
drama writers and we wanted to just do
that and and i think it was awesome and
i'm sorry molly is gone it's it's
painful will solar opposites
cross over with rick and morty i that i
am not the person to ask i don't know
how we would manage to do a crossover
you know being that there are two
completely separate
studios and so on and so forth so
probably not but
i don't know maybe
wired audience thank you so much for
taking the time to watch this nonsense
um i don't know why you would and i just
want to promote my new
soda line no i'm kidding this isn't
anyway bye bye everybody i don't have a
soda line see you guys